la première vidéo qui est sorti montrant
des soldats Ukrainiens en train
apparemment d'entrer dans un village
jusqu'à la occupé par les forces russes
venaient de la 68e brigade et de La
Redoute c'est un village situé au sud de
la ville de velikenobile qui est une
ville contrôlée par l'Ukraine dans la
région de donuts mais juste au confins
avec la région des vaporisa où je me
trouve en ce moment à côté de Black
Odette mais il y a deux autres villages
qui pendant la journée ont aussi été
plutôt pendant la journée l'annonce de
leur libération a été à annoncée parce
que on pense que la libération est
arrivée un peu plus avant les Ukrainiens
attendent un peu avant de confirmer la
prise de tel ou telle village ou autre
territoire mais il s'agit de
nescuchenet et macarifca si vous
regardez la carte ces trois villages qui
sont très proches l'un des autres les
uns des autres mais c'est au moins
différentes qui les ont pris il votre
village entre un escochenet et macarif
Ka est difficile de voir comment ils ont
pu prendre une excuse nameka sans
prendre l'autre village qui est entre
les deux aussi il se peut qu'il y ait
d'autres endroits d'autres communes qui
ont été déjà repris par les forces
ukraines mais que ça n'a pas été annoncé
encore mais il est vrai aussi et les
Ukrainiens l'admet que leur armée
rencontre des difficultés à d'autres
endroits sur la lignée de front
notamment du côté de macifica qui est
juste à l'ouest de Donetsk où ils disent
que c'est plutôt les Russes qui sont en
train d'attaquer les Ukrainiens
bonjour
on sent encore ses conséquences et
notamment là où vous trouvez à vaporidja
oui alors ça pourrait déjà c'est tout un
autre bout de ce qui était le réservoir
de carouka un lac artificiel est énorme
de 18 milliards de mètres cubes ici vous
voyez que le niveau d'eau est descendu
de manière assez significative mais pas
vraiment depuis hier je pense que ça
s'est stabilisé depuis hier on ignore
pour le moment exactement combien il
reste de ce barrage de carouka est-ce
que le fleuve va revenir à ces niveaux
des années 50 avant que le barrage était
construit à Kaoka ou est-ce que ça va se
stabiliser avec tout de même un petit
lac mais ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est
une perte en haut qui était utilisée
pour alimenter plusieurs villes
plusieurs
communautés rurales et surtout des
fermes l'agriculture les fermes les plus
sévèrement affectées par
la perte des eaux qu'ils utilisaient
pour l'irrigation
surtout sur la rive sud du fleuve qui
est actuellement
occupé par les forces russes mais sur le
côté nord qui est occupé qui qui reste
contre les par l'Ukraine il y a aussi
des femmes qui sont très sévèrement très
très sévèrement affecté c'est même
peut-être une banque route qui se
profile et la terre désertification
m'ont dit si une solution n'est pas
trouvée je me suis rendu sur l'un de ces
fermes c'était au lexifca près de
nicopole je pense qu'on peut maintenant
regarder mon reportage qui est position
français par Laura combo
les employés de cette ferme dans la
région de ni pro petrovsk sont encore
sous le choc
le niveau de l'eau est descendu de plus
de 8 mètres nous n'en avons plus assez
les vergers vont mourir nous n'avons
plus de système d'irrigation la flore et
la faune sont déjà mortes
celle-ci est vivante mais elle ne
parvient pas à ramper jusqu'à l'eau
alors elle va mourir aussi et ça va puer
et les gens nous sommes 8 dans ma
famille mon beau-fils est rentré blessé
par balle du front comment nettoyer ses
blessures nous n'avons plus d'eau
comment survivre en tant qu'humain
[Applaudissements]
était en charge de manœuvrer les pompes
qui prenaient l'eau de cette partie du
réservoir de kakovka pour irriguer les
cultures aujourd'hui les pompes sont à
l'arrêt quand le barrage a sauté la
pression de l'eau a détruit le canal
pour tenter de sauver ses cultures
Mireille l'eau et ses collègues prennent
de l'eau dans cette étang mais cela ne
suffira pas
constater l'ampleur de la baisse il ne
nous en reste plus que pour une semaine
cette ferme est gigantesque presque 4000
hectares et un gros employeur nous
avions de grands projets nous étions en
train de travailler de nous développer
de booster l'économie et de fournir des
emplois et regarder tout se dire pour
rien
[Applaudissements]
les fermiers ne se laissent pas abattre
les travaux pour réparer le système de
pompage ont déjà démarré mais l'eau
continue de s'écouler du réservoir et
personne n'a de solution pour l'arrêter